Monday's horrific mass shooting at the
DC Navy Yard left 12 victims dead and
more than a dozen people wounded it's
raised impassioned understandable but
ultimately misguided calls for more gun
control the fact is legislation should
almost never be crafted in the heat of a
crisis whether it's truly awful drug
laws pushed in the wake of high-profile
celebrity deaths or national security
measures rushed on read through Congress
after the 911 attacks legislation should
be the product of serious and
dispassionate deliberation northeastern
university's James Allen Fox has firmly
established that there is no upper trend
of mass shootings over the past 40 years
and when it comes to violent crime the
trend is clearly down FBI statistics
show that murders committed with
firearms dropped between two thousand
eight and two thousand twelve over the
past decade rape sexual assault robbery
and aggravated assault committed with
weapons has declined by twenty six
percent overall violent crime rates are
about half of what they were twenty
years ago the Navy Yard gunman Aaron
Alexis somehow managed to get a security
clearance to work at a military
installation despite getting booted from
the Navy and having a history of
gun-related violence mental instability
and erratic behavior the Pentagon is
auditing its security clearance and
hiring process for its bases one assumes
that other public and private workplaces
will follow suit of course that comes
too late to offer any comfort to the
families friends and coworkers mourning
the dead and wounded but in the end it's
far more likely to be effective than any
sort of gun control legislation rush
through Congress
you